this is how you make some of the best
air fryer nuggets but surprise I'm using
tofu it's super crispy but juicy on the
inside I swear I have cracked the code
first press all that water out water
means soggy nuggets and nobody wants
that then I break it into rough chunks
to give it this cryy texture and then my
secret ingredient is chicken bullan this
is pretty obvious but it makes it taste
like chicken then I toss it with oil
vinegar and corn starch until generously
coated I like to cook these in the air
fryer so they get extra crispy and then
we serve it with our favorite dip and
enjoy let's see if the kids like it good
I actually like it